- [Voiceover] Blue food
coloring can be oxidized
by household bleach, which
contains hypochlorite ion,
or OCI-, to form colorless products,
as represented by the equation above.
So we have this equation where
we have blue food coloring,
which has this chemical formula,
and it's reacting with
bleach, or hypochlorite,
and it's making colorless products.
So we're getting this color
change from blue to colorless.
A student used a spectrophotometer
set at a wavelength of 625 nanometers
to study the absorbance
of the food coloring
over time during the bleaching process.
In the study, bleach is
present in large excess,
and I will underline that
'cause that's important.
It's present in large excess
so that the concentration
of hypochlorite is essentially constant
throughout the reaction.
The student used data from the study
to generate the graphs below.
So we'd like to answer, in part a,
based on the graphs
above, what is the order
of the reaction with respect
to the blue food coloring?
So we have a lot of information here.
We have these three graphs.
If we write absorbance as A, we're looking
at the concentration of A over time.
We're looking at the ln of A over time,
the natural log, and we are also, lastly,
looking at one over the
concentration A over time.
So, we would like to
know, what is the order
of the reaction with respect to our blue?
My first instinct when I see this problem,
is actually to be a little bit panicky
because, hey we have a
lot of information here,
so how do we deal with it?
We also have a little bit more information
for this problem.
We also have the equation sheet.
So this is the part of the equation sheet
that's relevant for this problem.
So it's all of the equations
that have to do with kinetics,
which is looking at reaction rates,
so that is what we're looking at here.
So we have three possible things
that might be helpful for this problem.
Maybe not, right?
So we have this first
equation which gives us
the first order integrated rate law.
We have the second
equation, which gives us
the second order integrated rate law,
and we have this third equation
which is actually an
equation for the half-life.
So it's saying half-life is .693
divided by k, and that is the half-life
for a first order reaction.
And the important thing to remember here,
which will come up again in a second,
is that this is a constant,
because k is a constant,
so our half-life is also a constant
for a first order reaction.
So that's the information we have.
Let's look back at our graphs.
We're gonna start by looking
at just the first graph.
It turns out we can get
a lot of information
just by looking at the
concentration of A over time.
So if we look at this first graph,
and we look at the concentration
of our blue stuff going down over time,
we can see immediately
that this is not linear.
So the fact that it's not linear
immediately tells us it's not zero order.
If it was zero order, we would expect
to see a straight line,
which I will draw in pink,
with a dotted line because that's not
actually what we're seeing.
So it's not zero order.
We can also get some more information
by looking at this one graph.
We know it's not zero order.
Can we tell from this first
graph if it's first order?
And the answer is, we actually can.
If you remember from looking
at the equations sheet,
we said that first order reactions,
so for first order reactions, we know,
and I'd say this is maybe one of
the most important things
about first order reactions,
is that half-life is constant.
So that means that the time it takes
for the concentration to go down
to half of what it was,
is the same no matter what
your initial concentration is, no matter
what point in your reaction you're at.
So that's something we
can actually investigate
just by looking at this first graph.
We can see how much time it takes
to get to half the concentration,
and see if that's something
that changes over time.
So for example, if we
start with .8 right here,
half of .8 is .4,
so we can see how much time it takes
to get from .8 to .4, which is right here,
and if we go down we can
see it takes 20 seconds
to have the concentration
starting at .8 absorbance units.
We can look at the half-life
now to go from .4 to .2.
So if we go from .4 to .2,
and I will change colors
to make this look more obvious.
We'll do this in orange.
So going from .4 to .2
takes another 20 seconds.
And so we can do this again and again.
We could go from .2 to .1.
We'll just see the
continuation of a pattern here,
which is that, we can see that
it always takes 20 seconds
to halve the concentration.
And so the fact that half-life is constant
based on Graph I, immediately tells us
that our reaction is first order
because our half-life is constant.
We don't even have to look
at any of the other graphs.
There is another way you
could do this problem.
You might remember, based on
the equations that we have,
or based on just equations you know
off the top of your head.
So one reason we know, and
one reason we could say
this is first order, is
because t 1/2 is constant.
The other reason why we
know this is first order is,
when a reaction is first
order in your reactant,
you know that graphing ln of your reaction
versus time, gives you a straight line,
and we can see from Graph II
that this is the case.
So we have these two pieces of evidence,
from Graph I and Graph II, that tell us
that this particular reaction
is actually first order
with respect to the blue food coloring.